[Music]
1979 was a momentous year in the Middle
East the egyptian-israeli peace treaty
Saddam Hussein becoming president of
Iraq and the Soviet invasion of
Afghanistan but in retrospect the most
significant event is the Iranian
Revolution an anniversary we mark on
February 11 the revolution removed the
shop would be now chief proxy in this
strategically vital but highly volatile
part of the world worse it brought to
power regime that is defined the u.s. as
its principal enemy ever since despite
repeated efforts by American
administrations to find a path toward
peace since 1979 the most constant
threat we've faced in the region has
been Iran's relentless enmity which is
aggressively pursued by killing
Americans attacking American military
forces and allies and arming groups that
seek to overturn the regional status quo
by violence as Americans debate our role
in the Middle East it's worth
remembering why many fear it would be
dangerous to leave Iran's dogged
aggression against the United States its
friends and interests which started 40
years ago what do you think the future
holds for us Iran relations let us know
in your comments also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more research and
videos from AEI